se jacta de ser el país de la libertad
hace casi 50 años eeuu legalizó el
aborto en todo el país la histórica
decisión del tribunal supremo de 1973 lo
estableció como un derecho
constitucional hasta la viabilidad es
decir hasta el momento en que un feto
puede vivir fuera del útero que ahora se
considera alrededor de las 23 semanas de
gestación
pero el caso roe versus weight también
suscitó movimientos anti abortistas
liderados por grupos religiosos que se
fueron politizando en 1967 ronald wigan
fue uno de los primeros gobernadores del
país en legalizar el aborto en su estado
california pero para ganar las
elecciones presidenciales de 1980 reagan
decidió que necesitaba el voto
evangélico así que cambió su postura y
se declaró contrario al aborto
no debemos descansar y les prometí que
no descansaré hasta que una enmienda
sobre la vida humana forme parte de
nuestra constitución
desde entonces los republicanos se han
redoblado y el movimiento ha ganado
terreno quiere que el tribunal anule la
sentencia de robert sus week
warcraft bueno si ponemos otros dos o
quizás tres jueces eso sucederá y eso
sucederá automáticamente porque estoy
poniendo jueces pro-vida en la corte
white isssteson de cord durante su
mandato donald trump pre modelo
dramáticamente la corte suprema los
jueces conservadores ahora son la
mayoría con los derechos reproductivos
en peligro y después de darlo por
sentado durante muchos años los
estadounidenses a favor del aborto se
están reuniendo
es una lucha que nos va a llevar a todos
a ganar y estoy aquí para decir que no
vamos a retroceder
de acuerdo
el 61 por ciento de la población dice
que el aborto debe ser legal en la
mayoría de las circunstancias